auf der anderen seite gibt es natürlich
noch das problem mit mit bernd egger
ja gerne
gern hätte
ambitionen
wir haben hacker der mann heißt gern
hätte ich verstehe nicht glauben sie
dass es lustig oder röcke
[Musik]
erst mal lieber schön dich zu sehen man
habe ich heute gute laune mich zieht
heute nichts runter warum jetzt auf den
jetzt bleibt doch mal hier weißt du
genau wegen einem solchen verhalten
sagen die immer wir würden sie in die
rechte ecke stellen du meinst in die
rechte ecke in der sie schon die ganze
zeit stehen ganz genau und deswegen
verfolge ich da er einen integrativen
ansatz wobei integration da vielleicht
das falsche stichwort ist es geht darum
mit den leuten zu reden und das mache
ich die afd kommt zu wort
carsten van ryssen redet mit professor
doktor jörg leuten vor den wahlen in
baden-württemberg gibt es eine
fernsehdebatte im swr bei der die alv
nicht dabei sein wird da wollen wir vom
zdf ganz klar sagen da machen wir nicht
mit das ist nicht unsere sache
deshalb kommen sie heute bei uns zu wort
wie genau lief das mit dem swr
der swr meine ich meine sie sind nicht
eingeladen waren oder wieder ausgeladen
worden also das ist schon ein
unterschied ist sondern nicht eingeladen
wir werden das kann ich auch auf meine
frau wie zum beispiel sagen sehr gerne
eingeladen
die ist auch sehr viel beliebter als ich
also keine ahnung warum
vermutlich weil die anderen sie einfach
nicht so gut kennen wie ich mit welchen
parteien können sie sich perspektivisch
eine zusammenarbeit vorstellen also
ein bisschen abstrakt denken wieso ein
linksbündnis rot rot grün auf
bundesebene also politiker und andere
lager diese persönlich schätze putzen
sich eigentlich selber noch also auch
für unsere frauen muss ja auch mal
putzen sie eigentlich selber im haushalt
noch machen sie damit im haushalt so
irgendwie also grund zu hause auch die
spülmaschine einräumen
ich nehme auch mal meinen wann bricht in
die hand und machen selbst wenn ich
ihnen jetzt etwas da gibt es antworten
also denken sie dass sie das nicht ein
zu wollen sie kommt da schon zu weit
also wlan
wir meinen dass gehört die bahn ja
selbstverständlich verschiedenen sind
denn auf der straße ergibt die bahn
relativ ungewöhnlich wenig sind können
wir ganz schnell kurzen moment still
sein
ja ich bedanke mich das
damit gebe ich zurück
da habe ich echt abgeliefert was ganz
ehrlich bin ich nicht auch dein
heimliches vorbild also ich bin ja mir
ist es ja so dass ich nicht nur ein
vorbild habe sondern nehme mich da an
den großen der geschichte orientiere zum
beispiel an martin luther king barack
obama claus kleber sagt noch mal wissen
was bei dir
das ist natürlich in die ebenfalls gut
dass du bei deinen drehst dann auch oft
eine legende an deiner seite hast von
der du lernen kannst
naja csu gegen fdp marken jack wir
wollen wissen wo wird der gemeinde
bierzelt bayer besser bedient ja du
weißt ja schon lasse bei der alv die
pressekommentare die sind ganz lieb
[Musik]
im marken jack volksnähe zum
parteivorsitzenden ja der größte
vorsitzende bernd lucke hält einzug
bernd lucke das sind 45 kilogramm
geballte populistische power seehofer
zehn extra punkte wenn sie stehenbleiben
seehofer nur bernd lucke geht auf
tuchfühlung mit dem volk 30 punkte für
die afd
im marken jack drogenmissbrauch wir sind
hier von marken jack csu gegen fdp
müssen hier wissenschaftliche
untersuchung vornehmen da wie kurzer
hand nehmen
doch nicht wie nahe bin ich bin
wissenschaftlich versteht ist ja ja ja
ja ich glaube ich schaue aber enden
könnten gut nicht köln design der vor 45
jahren neue haschisch kraft
hallo ich bräuchte gerade mal eine
dna-probe eine dna-probe sind ein
wissenschaftliches magazin also jetzt
zum beispiel ein haar von ihrem bad
könnten sie uns das gibt dann nehmen sie
das doch das tut nicht weh einen
abstrich partie
alles klar vielen dank bitteschön
die csu ist drogenfrei zehn punkte im
marken jack angst vor den moslems haben
wir schon seit das exil on gibt und wo
es die meisten verbrechen verübt werden
hauptsächlich und auch die hemmschwelle
hin dass sie heute frau zwecks fünf euro
bringen
diese analysen und den ausländern her
also bestimmte auf jeden fall höher als
in deutschland
bayer macht es nicht er bringt eben
keine ältere frau gegen geld um genau
zum beispiel dass sie bitten sätze zu
vervollständigen wie diesen hier der
islam der islam gehört zur
internationalen welt aber nicht
es ist so ein teil von deutschland
es müssten nicht unbedingt noch mehr
zuwanderung von muslimischen ländern
gefördert werden
folgende situation stellen sie sich vor
ihr sohn hat sich verlobt wir haben
jetzt drei partner zur auswahl eine
verschleierte muslima b eine schwarze
jüdin oder c ein anderer mann was ich
dann keine vorteile
das ist ja schon am schlimmsten oder
angst vor dem moslem bei beiden parteien
jeweils zehn punkte im marken jack
respekt vor den staatsmedien wer war das
werden jetzt gerade auf dem green war
ich nicht das kann ich garantieren
ich werde niemanden verpflichten
wir waren nicht und deutschland darf
niemals rot rot grün regieren das ist
mir das mal eine mehrheit
zusammenbringen wenn die fdp im
erreichung die sind lauter als der
redner vorne muss dann ist ja ok aber
nicht übertreiben
warum darf ich sie fragen warum warum
sich also kritisch eingestellt sind
man kennt ihn eingestellt bin das was
wir glauben sie dass sie mit bezwecken
wenn sie hier
blödsinn betreiben sie machen eine
aufnahme die ist für die öffentlichkeit
ja das ist das ist normales kann sich
das ist normales fernsehgeschäft
ungehalten zu verbreiten
lügen zu verbreiten in vereinigungen zu
verbreiten der stadt wahrheiten ist dass
ihr geschäft auch sein sehr demokratie
wo jeder etwas sagen kann was er möchte
sagen sie erhält man sagen sie was sie
möchten nein
die csu hat respekt zehn punkte und
damit steht der sieger fahrt im markt es
gibt einen eindeutigen populismus sieger
und franz josef strauß kann richtig
stolz sein ob die afd
herzlichen glückwunsch im heute-show
populismus check holt die afg den klaren
sieg du meinst in siegen
siehst du das meine ich während ich für
verständigung sorgen gibt es bei dir nur
draufhauen draufhauen draufhaut du bist
auch so ein typ wie alexander gauland
beim baden seiner anziehsachen cloud
punkt eins dann gucken wir uns doch
jetzt mal an wie gut das mit deiner
verständigung klappt ja und punkt zwei
die wahlkampf in berlin eigentlich nicht
langweilige sache außer einer afg
kandidatin tritt in einem linksgrünen
versifften kita wie sibylle schmidt
hallo
suchen sie die gefahr nein warum kennt
man sie in kreuzberg eigentlich als afd
kandidaten kennen sie frau schmidt nicht
wirklich würden sie frau schmidt wäre
nicht vorstellt kommt zurück
vielleicht haben sie die gegenargumente
und können für die alv de werben
du brauchst keine angst haben in dieser
partei sind menschen aus allen anderen
parteien die haben sich da
zusammengefunden und momentan etwas
gegen die unkontrollierte
masseneinwanderung zu machen
hast du verstanden hab ich ja erst mal
kurz wiederholen auf meine sprache der
wiege sprach sie damals wollte mir jetzt
gerade erklären das was für die afg
sprich als da wären das die so schlimm
wie gehen wir zu den kommunisten
schweinen der typischen kreuz der
kapitalismus schweine system was fällt
der afg dazu ein
es ist ein kann der buchladen hier nun
sollen sie ihre meinung äußern
berührt mich nicht so wird auch mal
reingehen fragen die sie kennen heute
schon sicher drin nicht
wir gehen jetzt mal zusammen zu den
grünen
das gibt es in ordentlich zunder die
grill nämlich hallo ich bin der kanten
und das ist die frau schmidt von der afg
und neun mal kurze mit euch ein bisschen
sprechen ist das möglich wenn die hfg
kommt bringen die grünen erst mal ihre
plagen in sicherheit und provoziert das
mal gesagt wer war ihr auch so im video
oper muss immer auf dem stuhl sitzen ist
immer somit gibt es zwischen den grünen
und der afg mehr gemeinsamkeiten als
mache meinen annimmt sind ja auch gegen
tipp oder die heftig denke schon
also wir haben wahrscheinlich
gemeinsamkeiten
das lässt sich ja gar nicht leugnen also
wahrscheinlich essen auch mit der der
afg manchmal butter brot
auch mal elegant meinen nikolaus als 4
empfänger trennen wurde unglaublich
die haben das geld wie gesagt dann wird
bezahlt eben dann gar kein hartz 4 wenn
sie das kind das ist nicht richtig dann
sollten sie sich informieren einen gt
von 1 zu sagen wo es mittagessen oder
richten immer gerne
es sind lauter spannende fragen die mich
wirklich brennend interessieren man
sieht sie nämlich gar nicht auf der
straße warum haben sie eigentlich
kandidaten auf ihrer landesliste die
verbindung ins rechtsextreme spektrum
haben gute frage warum ist mir die nicht
eingefallen
repariert dass die band spielt also glas
hier beispielsweise die integrierte
wieder verschließen was ja auch etwas
mit sozialer spezialität aus china
das darf welche nicht sehen dass ich ein
spezialteam der nacht nicht mehr für
kriege ich denn der antwort auf eine
frage wenn ich ihnen was zu essen holen
so ein leckerer tofu burger
beispielsweise sie wissen doch hier
vegan verspielt und links drin versetzt
und so dass zwei dinge haben sich für
mich heute bestätigt die ard hat keinen
plan und die grünen können nicht grillen
vielen dank an unseren reporter hans
christian ströbele so zu meiner
verteidigung sie sagen ich hab' echten
hunger garten du weißt ganz genau wie
schlecht das essen in der zdf kantine
ist apropos zum kotzen
ich war 2017 jahr auf dem parteitag der
verständigung als ralf sag es nicht gut
da nicht aber zufällig war ich 2017
nicht nur auf dem parteitag einer partei
die zum kotzen ist und deren name ich
hier nicht nennen sondern auch auf dem
parteitag der afd
und mit diesen persönlichen bildern
möchte ich euch heute entlassen ohne
mich viel spaß eine parteistrafe eine
hochschwangere frau ab so geht es zu bei
der afd
sehen sie dazu meinen erschütternden
bericht
die wenn sich an die zeit zurückerinnern
als frauke petry vorsitzende der afg war
sie ist vorsitzender stehen und bleibt
auch vorsitzender der beitrag wird am
nächsten freitag ausgestrahlt also von
daher gesehen gewissen natürlich stellt
sich jetzt die große frage ist ins team
träger sind die team bauland keine
antwort nicht jetzt warum stimmung zur
aus bereits es ist dass es doch ziemlich
klar es gibt ja kein team petri petri
tritt nicht an und damit gut können sie
zu machen
ich habe nie vorsitzender werden wollen
und bin auch nicht parteivorsitzender
werden
und sie sollten auch mal ein alter
bedenken ja das ist gut
auf alten fahrrädern mein fahrrad fahren
das wird der vergleich passt nicht so
recht daran hatten platten was das war
ich bin nicht so recht benutzer mit mit
stützrädern ich gehe davon aus dass wir
auf diesem pfad geeint hervorgehen
werden
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
irgendwie das leben ist wie sagen dass
sie diese ganzen demonstranten ja
bezahlt werden von irgendwelchen spd
leuten ok bekommt denn so ein
demonstrant von der spd wenn er hier
demonstrieren fragen sie doch der sich
sagen sie müssen sie anscheinend wissen
es wird bußgeld gegeben von 20 euro
streikgeld ich war bei berlin bei der
demonstration 20 euro
so war das damals wenn man wenn man wenn
man draußen gegen die ft demonstriert
gibt 20 euro bar auf die hand sondern
das werde ich ihnen letztlich sagen
heute das hat natürlich auch prominenz
hier auf dem parteitag mitte hulk hogan
europa-parteitag hier also ich kann nur
deutsch denken sie sprechen sehr gut
deutsch walkerin man kennt sich für ihre
catcher vergangenheit sie sind ein tier
gewesen haben die leute auf die matte
geschickt davon absehen und das ist
unhöflich was sie machen wir
unterhaltungsportal sind sie auch immer
jetzt geht es ihm jetzt welches bei den
kollegen schon wieder auf der anderen
seite gibt es natürlich noch das problem
mit bernd höcker
dr
ja gerne
gern hätte
ambitionen
wir haben hacker der mann als berg ich
verstehe nicht glauben sie das ist
lustig oder
also fried werden stimmt zwar nicht ganz
denn es geht ja mal so eine brücke auf
dem plakat ja ja ja ist das ganz klar ja
aber ich halte das nicht da es aber in
gedanken ist ja bei uns gedanken sind
wir auch bei ihm
hampel da schon wieder nicht wir haben
endlich überlegen habe jetzt wir müssen
reden
er hat nur ganz kurz jetzt will ich auch
nicht mehr genau wie ich bin bin ich
auch genauso wie hier von der tuttlinger
vermögen und es sind auch ein großer
öffentlich rechtlicher sender formal
gesehen also einfach mal tschüss sagen
wollte ich machen sie es gut
eine schöne zeit mit ihnen frauke petry
das war es als parteivorsitzender jetzt
geht es rein vielleicht ein letztes mal
aber gut dann kommt der nächste
[Applaus]
wenn euch das video gefallen hat lasst
doch einfach ein leichter und ein und
ein abo danke und in der und in der zdf
mediathek gibt es sogar schon eine
neueste best of wahnsinn oder warum muss
ich diese ganze sache eigentlich alleine
machen sagt du doch auch mal was
arschloch